what are you smoking right now i'm
smoking
exotic i'm smoking [__] made for animals
this [__] i'm smoking no like scarface
with snot and cocaine yes on the
movement
yes that's how i'm smoking weed
you're not snorting the weed right no
i'm not snorting the weed i was about to
say you'd be the first rapper to ever do
that
no what you calling that [__] that
[__] hitting the weed right now i'm
finna post him now
bishop don juan you saw him no i'm gonna
post him on my instagram when we leave
what was he doing see him be the first
one he smokes his blunts out his nose
bro
oh bro pull it up bro have you tried it
hell no he don't know
man i saw too many people snotting
cocaine when i was little let me ask you
this
have you ever done the edible thing yeah
i've done the edible thing but i don't
like the other one
i like the dab because you'll be your
dad
you'll [__] die
did you have like a bad edible
experience because you eat too much
edibles
you just gotta wait that [__] out it
ain't like you could eat it it gets in
your bloodstream so
i had a bad day what happened
like my my heart was being too fast bro
like you know
no it's [__] up like i had a bad
experience bro like coming home
from prison and mm-hmm thinking i'm
thinking i know what i'm doing going
there hit a [__] dab in their
mouth
and it's kind of crack head-ish because
there's the the torch
yeah it's not like you know what i mean
like you felt like i was hitting the
fight
yeah i'm saying like oh let's see he's
hitting it out the nose
oh no that's crazy bro and he's doing it
like like he's been doing this
like bro he viral i'm sending him
is that is that magic don juan yeah
that's that's the bishop man
oh man that's the [__] that's some old
she got some seventy [__] oh that's wild
70-60 [__]
dolomite [__] man yeah now the edibles
is a mother but the dab [__] is crazy
the first time i ever hit a dab and i
saw the thing with the the torch and
i said this [__] feels like crack
headish to me
and then you hit it and then your
[__] face is melted off
and then you have like the worst night
of your life which is what happened to
me